so found this rare on Twitter which I
want to share with you in this thread
another former McKinsey consultant
shares his top 10 learnings the
learnings that this person got away from
working for several years at McKinsey
and from these top 10 learnings I now
picked the five ones which I thought are
the most interesting ones and I will
provide you my commentary being a former
McKinsey consultant as well whether I
agree with what has been shared here I
know starting with the first one by the
way I have the best for the end so stick
with me I will now read out what this
gentleman wrote and then I will comment
on it so this gentleman writes there are
no experts in business I have always
optimized my decisions for maximum
learning even if tracking backwards in
my career like I did at the time with
the McKinsey move before I joined I'll
assume that people in the upper echelons
of the business world really knew what
they were doing that they were infused
with great wisdom and insights and
secret data that the rest of the world
didn't know about turns out they are
pretty much guessing much like the rest
of us that's why they had a bunch of
smart young people in the first place
now I know everyone is just figuring it
out on the go you don't need fancy Kratz
to have that go-getter mindset so my
very first Consulting internship after
University I can still vividly remember
the situation I was on the team spending
the first week there we already had lots
of meetings with clients and I was of
course very naive at the time I was 20
when I did my first internship with
McKinsey and at that time our mindset
was wow these senior business people all
these leaders in the corporate world
they must be light years ahead of me
when it comes to business in human when
it comes to knowledge when it comes to
problem solving and decision making
abilities while of course I was young
and inexperienced I very quickly
realized that of course the one thing is
domain knowledge of course someone who
has product in a specific field for 10
20 30 years knows a lot of things that
you do not know but this is not to be
confused with some type of super
intelligence some type of super
abilities that these people have that
wouldn't be possible for you to pick up
as well and for me this was quite
liberating because after some time I
learned that I can just walk in a new
industry in another company work on a
different function and very likely after
some time looking into it there's at
least some part there are some areas
where I can add real value next key
learning the basics meta I bump into all
the McKinsey colleagues this is what
this gentleman is writing who tell me
how they are perceived to be very sharp
but in reality they are just all
following some simple Basics steel
Manning arguments always having a goal
for meeting rephrasing a question for
clarity reiterating key insights from an
argument that was not well articulated
always some memorizing a discussion at
the end it's the Optics of the simplest
and dullest things that everyone does
which makes them seem highly Sharp and
this is indeed something that resonates
for me quite a lot as well and to some
extent You could argue that this is one
of the reasons why some people don't
like Consultants right but what you can
for sure not argue against is that many
consines are very good at what people
call perception management manage the
perception that other people have of
yourself there's one saying that is used
a lot in Consulting and this is that
perception is reality perception is
reality and you can use this in
different ways maybe you did a great job
at the work you did really excellent
work but if the perception of your team
lead of your client of your colleagues
is that actually you didn't contribute
that much then in the end of the day
this will not be perceived well this is
what it means perceptions reality but of
course you can also look at this from
the other way around right so if other
people have the perception that you are
very smart highly capable very
intelligent who cares what your real IQ
is right who cares on anything that
matters is that other people have this
perception of you and there are indeed a
lot of things that you learn rather
quickly in Consulting how to manage this
perception I created a video in the past
where I talked about some of these also
quite dirty sneaky little tips and
tricks that consign Supply I will link
it somewhere above here check it out but
this is definitely a skill that is not
to be undervalued especially if you have
the goal to really follow a corporate
career going forward that will be very
important for you next inside this
gentleman shared managing upwards there
is a hustle culture the harder you work
the more you will likely get worked you
work in dog years AKA first year at the
firm is equated to three years in other
Industries and companies that's a nice
saying a dog here okay so you sometimes
work with multiple partners who all want
100 from you pressure is immense you
must be able to manage up or you will
implode plus if you do that you end up
getting more more respect all around I
have hated confrontations and always
looked for peace paths then I learned
methods like how to say no how to
disagree how to prioritize Etc these
skills now help me massively to manage
expectations and just succeed in my role
and this is very true as well and also a
key learning that you will pick up over
the first year or so of your career in
the beginning you have the perception
that you need to please everyone you
need to do everything after all you're
working for such a firm like McKinsey
BCG band right like clearly you need to
do a lot and of course it's very
difficult I'd say to manage it all in a
way that really you don't have long
working hours that's true as well but at
some point you need to realize that no
you don't need to say yes to everyone
you don't need to accept every little
task that you get it's absolutely fair
to give pushback to your partners to
your project leads and then of course
the interesting thing is where then
skill comes into play is how to do it in
a way that it's not perceived as you
being lazy or it's not being perceived
as offensive but it's actually being
perceived as a very fair pushback of
fair contribution next learning you do
not need to have all the answers at the
start you're expected to jump cold into
new unrelated domains and new business
functions sales Tech marketing things
fly in from the left field all the time
I remember one Friday I was asked to fly
out to San Francisco for a week next
week I worked on a project in Investment
Banking all the while I was working on
high pressure covered projects but again
guess what you figure it out every time
this changed me I jumped in knowing I'll
figure it out again and this is probably
one of the most powerful Fields you'll
also learn in Consulting you're
confronted with new topics all the time
topics where you need to work together
with people who have Decades of
experience in this domain and again you
need to learn to First not be shocked by
this not be paralyzed by this but to
read up on things make yourself
knowledgeable in a short amount of time
of course the big consulting firms offer
lots of resources on that you will often
have more experienced team members also
with the specific industry and function
knowledge you can talk to you can
interview you will be able regularly to
reach out to internal and external
experts on the topic so there's a lot
about capability building looking into
the knowledge that you need to pick up
but this again empowers you to do this
also in other words Consultants often
are not afraid to step into a new
company in a later role do something
that didn't really do before because
again this is exactly what they will be
doing throughout the course of their
Consulting career next learning and I
kept this for the end because this is
arguably the most iconic value the most
iconic principle that the firm McKinsey
stands for and this is the obligation to
descent so as this gentleman put it
obligation to the send a McKinsey value
crucial to collaboration Harmony is the
obligation to descend it's
counterintuitive for most why would
descent result in more Harmony at the
firm you're not only allowed to disagree
with someone more senior than you but
you're also obliged to do so meaning
from day one McKinsey expects you to
have a point of view and to share it as
such everyone participates in a meeting
sharing their perspective also very
Junior people remember you don't have to
be right you just need to have a
perspective though as an immigrant I
have always had it's subdued in front of
my seniors giving me a safe environment
to voice my thoughts and knowing there
would be no judgment breaking past
mental barriers and putting my best work
forward needless to say I'm trying to
Harbor the same environment in my
business now obligation to the scent a
very crucial piece of information here
right so it's not only that you have the
right to descent to contribute of you
disagree if you don't agree with what
someone is saying but you have the
obligation the duty to do so and what
this means is that this creates a
culture where indeed everyone is forced
to think about the topics all the time
what is my perspective on this what is
my point of view on this do I actually
agree what is being put forward here and
then if someone asks me I need to also
of course be able to provide reasons why
I agree with someone why I disagree with
someone and this rigorous method this
rigorous school of thought is something
that arguably is something that really
shapes and influences many consultants
working in firms like McKinsey
throughout their Professional Care
career and a very valuable learning
indeed hope you found this inspiring let
me know in the comments are there any
other learnings from Consulting you'd
like to add to that I would be very
interested to read this trust this is
true for all the others here as well if
you do any value out of this video at
all hit the like button for the YouTube
algorithm hit subscribe thank you for
all the members of from learning I will
also leave the Twitter handle of the
gentleman who posted this in the video
description my name is heimlich I
release weekly videos here on the
channel see you again next week and bye